محمد حيدر اسطنبولي الطفل اللبناني عمره
ست سنوات سبب حاله حزن في عموم لبنان
والعالم العربي بعد تداول خبر وفاته بسبب
توقف مفاجئ في عضله القلب خبر وفاه الطفل
تحول لعنوان في الاخبار بسبب قصه الوفاه
فالطفل مات من الخوف حرفيا مات من الخوف
يعني في اللي صار انه ظهر قدام احمد في
حديقه مخصصه للاطفال في صور مجموعه من
الشباب والشابات لابسين اسود في اسود
وشايلين سيوف حديديه في يدهم وكله كده
علشان فيديو بيصوروه لتيك توك المجموعه
مكونه من شابين وبنتين قرروا انهم يمثلوا
مشاهد رعب في مكان للعب الاطفال عشان قال
انه يضحكوا متابعيهم على تيك توك ومحمد
كان الضحيه فبعد ما طلعوا قدامه افتكا من
وجع في قلبه في ناس قالت قضاء وقدر لكن في
اهالي في المدينه بيطالبوا بمحاسبه الشباب
وتم بالفعل ايقافهم بتهمه التسبب بالقتل
لكن عموما وفاه محمد جددت على منصات سؤال
عن الخوف وعلاقته بالموت يعني احنا بنقول
في حواراتنا العاديه لما نوصف موقف مرعب
جدا انه بموت من الخوف يعني او بنقول انه
مت من الخوف كنوع من صيغه المبالغه لما
احد يخاف او يترعب جدا لكن هل علميا فعلا
ممكن شخص يموت من الخوف الدكتور اسلام ابو
سيدو استشاري امراض القلب هو الزميل
الكليه الامريكيه لامراض القلب والشرايين
حيجاوبنا على هذا السؤال اهلا فيك معنا
دكتور اسلام هل نقدر فعليا نقول انه الخوف
ممكن يكون قاتل
مساء الخير سيدتي موضوع كثير مهم وحساس
ويمكن احنا بحكم طبيعه عملنا كاطباء قلب
يمكن بنبه اللي حوالينا ومننبه اصدقائنا
بموضوع الخوف موضوع الخوف سيدتي يسبب هجمه
شديده من ارتفاع ماده الادرينالين وماده
الادرينالين هي الماده المسببه لتسارع
ضربات القلب بشكل عنيف بدي انبه حضرتك انه
هذا الماده
الساده المشاهدين طبعا انه هذه الماده لما
يزيد افرازها بكميات هائله عن حاجه الجسم
المتعارف عليها للاسف بتحس خلايا
الكالسيوم او ماده الكالسيوم على التقلص
الشديد لهذه ماده الكالسيوم لما تدخل في
عضله القلب وتندفع الى خلايا القلب
الداخليه تسبب تقلصات شديده في عضله القلب
اللي بيؤدي انه عضله القلب تستمر بضخ الدم
بطريقه متسارعه جدا بدون ما ترتاح للاسف
هذه قد تسبب نوبه قلبيه مفاجئه
وهذا الحديث يعني متعارف سابقا وصارت فيه
عنه دراسات كثيره موضوع الافراز الزائد
لماده
وطبعا اللي بتسبب فيها اللي هو الجهاز
العاطفي السنبثاوي اللي بنحكي عنه والجهاز
العاطفي
الفرح والحزن يعني مو ضروري انه بس مثلا
شخص بيفجعوا او كده ممكن حتى من الفرح
يعني الواحد يموت يعني
احسنت ستي في حالات نادره جدا الحزن
الشديد والفرح الشديد هم حاله من الافراز
الشديد لماده الادرينالين ومن هنا تعرفنا
عن من من 15 سنه قاعدين عم نحكي عن
متلازمه القلب المنكسر اتاكد والمتسبب
الرئيسي في الظاهره للاسف الشديد هو
الافراز الشديد لماده الادرينالين قد
يتسبب بحدوث نوبات قلبيه مفاجئه تؤدي الى
الوفاه طبعا في ناس عندهم قابليه او
استعداد اكثر من ناس اخرين حابه اسالك عنه
دكتور اسلام يعني هل هذا الشيء ممكن يحصل
لازم الشخص يكون اساسا مثلا نقول عنده ضعف
في القلب او مثلا عنده استعداد وراثي او
ما الى ذلك ولا حتى القلب الصحيح او
الانسان الصحيح الصحي ممكن يتعرض لنفس
الشيء سؤال رائع يعني بصراحه اللي عنده
قابليه اكتر هو الانسان اللي عنده
اعتلالات هذا الانسان سواء كان يعني عنده
امراض سابقه عنده ضعف القلب سابق صحيح هم
فرصتهم هدول اكثر بكثير من الناس الاصحاء
لكن حتى الاصحاء يا سيدتي
معرضين وبشكل كبير لهذه الظاهره يعني
الناس ما يفكروا انه والله هذا فلان كان
سوي
وهو يعني ما حتصير له هذه النوبه لا للاسف
الشديد حتى الاسوياء والاصحاء معرضين لكن
تتضاعف كميه الاصابه بشكل كبير للناس
المرضى او الغير الصحه او اللي عندهم
قابليه سواء اعتلالات سابقه او امراض
سابقه او خلافه
يؤدي على طول لنوبه شديده وتسبب الوفاه او
مثلا لا نوبه قلبيه يمكن النجاه منها او
ما الى ذلك يعني قد ايش الفرق بين الاثنين
ممكن يصير هلا هو نادرا جدا اصابه بنوبه
قلبيه انه تؤدي الى الوفاه اكون صادق معك
الا اذا صار اضطراب في ضربات القلب اللي
هو صار حاله من الرجفان البطيني وما في
حواليه حدا للمريض يسعفه فلذلك ممكن نخسره
هذا لكن لو في حواليه مستشفى او كذا او
دائره صحيه او مكان قريب وتنس زي ما
بقولوا شوهد وبدا انعاش القلب ممكن ينقذ
حياته لكن اذا كان عن اي مكان صحي للاسف
ممكن نخسره هذا الانسان
في حاله طفل يعني هذا طفل اللي احنا
بنتكلم عنه في هذه الحاله طفل ما هو مسكين
هذا يمكن كان في مكان بعيد جدا عن
المستشفى وصار عنده نوبه الرجفان البطين
الى الوفاه المفاجئه على غير متوقع انه
اصحابه مثلا بخوفوا
بمزحوا او يتماسحه ومن هنا ننبه اطفالنا
وبشده عن موضوع الترويع وبصراحه حتى في
ديننا ديننا ينهي عن الترويع لانه هذه
الظاهره طبيه تؤدي الى الوفاه سيدي بغض
النظر حتى اطفال ولا كبار ولا الكلام هذا
كله المفروض ما احد يفجع احد يعني الصراحه
حركه بشعه وسخيفه يعني اصلا
[موسيقى]